elle a remontré quand même ce que vous
êtes en train de nous fabriquer voilà
elle nous fait un petit pendentif maison
voilà un petit pendentif france 3 et du
coup elle a démarré alors il ya plein
d'étapes en fait quand vous faites un
bijou mais là on est à l'étape de la
soudure mais qui est vraiment pas la
dernière étape est ce que je disais
c'est qu'à chaque fois vous maltraitez
le métal vraiment offrir un petit pot et
là on le brûle on le frappe
on le coupe donc on lui fait un petit
peu de mal mais mais au final après une
fois qu'on la décaper limay et poli on
lui redonne toute sa toute sa beauté et
tout son éclat son brillant vous aimez
travailler tous ces métaux précieux
métaux précieux uniquement en fait c'est
ça essentielle socialement je travaille
essentiellement l'argent et l'or mais le
bronze laiton le cuivre donc pour tout
ce qui est ciselure et puis aussi pour
avoir un petit peu toutes les gammes de
prix en fait je vais commencer vraiment
à des prix assez bas jusqu'à des tarifs
joaillerie beaucoup plus élevé en
fonction du travail qui a à faire et des
matériaux utilisés
oui parce que vous aimez aussi vous
enfin vous fait pas forcément de série
vous faites beaucoup de pièces uniques
en fait énormément je travaille
essentiellement à la commande donc
d'après soit des dessins client soit
voilà des gens qui m'explique un petit
peu ce qu'ils veulent qu'ils me donnent
des thèmes moi je réalise les dessins et
je leur propose après différentes choses
mais j'ai aussi ma propre collection je
fais très peu effectivement de série
j'en ai un petit peu de la petite série
pour avoir un petit peu tout toutes les
gammes de tarifs mais je travaille
essentiellement la pièce unique et la
commande particulière
alors je voudrais commente quand même
différent de choses on est ronde on n'a
pas ce que moi je savais pas du tout
comment vous travaillez
du coup là alors ça paraît un peu
étrange ça fait une énorme bague mais
finalement ça c'est quoi enfin en fait
ça c'est votre modèle de bijoux en fait
c'est comme ça que vous modélisez vos
bijoux au départ ça c'est une maquette
en fait je vais et je vais commencer à
ébaucher du coup dans un tube de cire ma
forme de chevalière donc ça c'est le cv
uniquement les beaux chants celle au
début ensuite je vais sûrement relis mes
de chaque côté en fonction de la forme
de la table de la chevalière donc soit
elle va être ovale où on doit avoir une
forme blasonnés
donc on taille avec des limes c'est de
la cire de bijoutiers ensuite ce modèle
en cire va être va être pris en moule
plâtre et semoule va être chauffée et en
injecte le métal en fusion directement
dedans
une fois que le métal est cool et on va
le plonger dans l'eau qui va refroidir
le plâtre et du cou cassé et on va
récupérer le positif en métal d'accord
et donc justement ça c'est un pendentif
que vous avez terminé déjà et je les
écoute que je n'ai pas encore tout à
fait terminée à d'accord national j'ai
vu une création que j'ai vu qui
ressemble à ça et qu'elle est ça c'est
presque la même c'est presque le même
l'accord mais du coup donc ça ça donnera
lieu un pendentif en fait après et ça
c'est plutôt bien avancé encore c'est
pas ça c'est un peu plus avancés en tout
cas que la chevalière ça marche ça
marche ça marche
du coup pour ce qui nous concerne la en
fait on appris vous avez prix du métal
que une pièce de métal en fait en reste
une chute une plaque et à l'intérieur de
vous avez déjà découpé à la scie
c'est ça très fine ouais comme celle ci
oui ça et ensuite appris en fait là vous
allez vous avez soudé tout ensemble et
ça c'est quoi le petit le petit regret
c'est quoi le sertit sur d'accord met
une petite pierre pour mettre une pierre
intéressés ça donc là du coup j'ai
utilisé une plaque de métal que j'ai
découpé
j'ai découpé le 3 séparément je suis
venu avec un fils faire la bordure au
tourisme une bordure parce que je vais
émaillé du coup la partie entre le 3 et
la bordure d'accord je vais mettre un
émail bleu du monde et donc cette petite
ce petit cercle là que je suis venu
faire avec un petit morceau de fil
en gros d'accord que j'ai soudé va
servir à recevoir la pierre des corps
petite taupe bleu
donc là il nous reste a émaillé sa a
émaillé polir et sertir alors comment on
aimait y un peu de ça va se passer par
non ça va se passer avec sa voilà c'est
ça avec cette petite poudre là qu'on va
venir remplir
du coup toutes les zones qui vont êtres
bleus ouais et ensuite on va passer au
four à l'émail pour faire fondre cette
poudre qui en fait est ouvert donc ça va
fondre et faire une surface de verre
bien lisse et du coup après on va le
ressortir mva polir donc cette ce bijou
et elle coule à la petite-pierre qui va
se positionner ici qu'il sera bleu elle
aussi israël elle aussi bien évidemment
j'avoue respecter la charte
elle est parfaite